so
yo what up everyone hi um
i got crisis a day early so i thought
that we would play crisis
that's pretty much it um i don't feel
like there are that many fans of the
crisis series
you know it's always been known for uh
being
the games that you test your pc on but
um i actually really liked crisis 2 law
and very much enjoyed crysis 3 very
specifically for the predator
um i've spoken about that in the past
about how much fun i found that it's
like
i want to say you feel like batman in
those predator rooms even though batman
naturally does not kill people with
a bow or a suit that turns invisible but
whatever so i thought that we'd check
out crisis remastered um
it did have a bit of a shady reception
when the
trailer uh came out
is it just gonna stop me from game one
for some reason but for the record both
youtube and twitch made me select crisis
two
so we're gonna go normal
it is just crisis one okay that's cool
we can do it let's see how it looks
shall we
i can run crisis remastered it did
recommend medium settings for me though
so
that's worth noting thank you everyone
the yeah the cyberpunk news has been
something that i've had to hold on to
for a very long time so it's nice to
have it out there and
i didn't expect the reception to be as
positive as it was um
i really didn't like i thought people
would be like oh cool but people i don't
know
i felt like people cared like they cared
about a nice thing happening to me and
that was like very surprising today
i don't know why though um so thank you
everyone i appreciate it
i know i am a big donnie d uh my co-star
keanu and i really appreciate the
support
this doesn't seem good
are you having trouble loading bud
we're on a hunted down here
sometimes video games in a video game
um where cyberpunk is concerned you guys
know i did not
get to pick how i looked i did all of my
vo
um and
let me just tab out real quick that did
it fix the [ __ ] sometimes
and we just go back in i guess tabbing
out just took me to the menu
what's happened bud what are you doing
crisis come on
um the other question i don't know what
the name of my character is and yes it
is just my voice
yes of course
i don't remember this game at all it's
too long ago
oh thanks scorpio what mic do i use uh
this is a rode prod
pro caster podcaster or pro coster i
don't remember which one i have honestly
i think i need to upgrade though it
picks up a bit too much room sound but
um i love rode australian brand super
helpful
that does not look good it's not look
good
i feel like this looks like halo 1
which i love
this is
do you realize how epic they made it
nothing on our side
skies are clear over
this is like avengers vibes also tell me
if the game's too loud
hey no man you still with us okay that
looks a little better
okay listen up gentlemen intel reports a
significant military presence on the
island
we have the element of surprise so let's
use it the north koreans can't know
we're here
i won't even know what hits him can it
psycho
pay attention this is a covert operation
our job is to locate and be back i love
video games we're not at war here
not yet whoa profit do you even know if
these people are incredible
looks cleaner than you expected uh yes
for the record you guys i said
earlier in the stream people will
probably repeat it so if you see someone
else say it in chat
please answer them for me so i don't say
it over and over again uh for some
reason
twitch and youtube both only let me
choose um
crisis ii i wasn't able to choose crisis
one
so it says i'm playing crisis too i'm
absolutely not playing crisis too this
is precious one
uh crisis remastered also wasn't an
option so that's the issue with that
thank you darren oh that's awesome got
you back into gaming let's do that
go go
oh my gosh i'm touching the video game
oh that's sensitive
can i dive i feel like i should be able
to look look ladies and gentlemen it's
the original fortnite
this actually looks all right aside from
those textures up there
being exactly the same ain't the real
reason we're here
all
uh let's just ask you about cyberpunk
poor crisis
crisis um no my damn suit is gone
i've got no mane no reserve keep it
together
oh that's choppy
um no my uh decision not to review
cyberpunk is not related to me being in
the game because
i don't review games anymore anyway so i
wouldn't have anyway
of course you should never review a game
that you're in that would be absolutely
ridiculous
but i haven't reviewed games in two
years so i was never going to review
cyberpunk
i don't know why people thought i would
it's weird
i don't know if we need this i feel like
we've pretty much done
he got away i was too slow the video
feed is
um
is totally um a map like this a turtle
nope it's a crap [ __ ] hate crabs uh
there's totally a level like this in uh
oh it's c for crowd [ __ ] press control
strange
uh map like this in crisis three that i
totally remember really distinctly
but i don't remember this game very well
why why are these the controls
my gosh
you outdated son of a [ __ ] can we
change the
mapping maybe there we go lad
it's gonna be control thank you
throne is gonna be well i would want
that to be hold left control
you can't do that
space is fine
melee attack is v
reload checks out binoculars being b
checks out i don't know we'll see what
else i need to
adjust as i go i suppose but really i
just wanted crouch to be
controlled all right
there it is why is it so delayed okay
make sure your silencer is attached
look at my little rocket jump enemy
contact am i playing it on can it run
crisis mode
um technically no but we can do that too
if you'd like i am playing on medium and
i can up it
let's see if i can run crysis shall we
is there a way to just put everything
that's not gonna that's not gonna be
right why this is also controls terribly
i feel like this is going to break my pc
but i guess
we'll find out i don't have retracing
devastatingly
oh change all settings too there it is
literally write that okay
yes let's see what happens
this could break my pc i do plan to get
a new one
in the next six months
cover bud you're very good you are very
expensive and i really like you
but this may not work
there it goes there it goes
i guess the answer to can it run crisis
is
a fat note which i respect
for the record i respect
it's not gonna happen brian this is not
a sponsored video no
i just wanted to play crisis i don't do
sponsored streams
all right closing the game
all right pea bud oh am i gonna have to
task manager this
i might have to
yikes there you go
there you go well there you have it
uh this comes out tomorrow fyi
try again buddy try again
you've heard the highest mode just
intentionally breaks the game i could
see that being a thing
well i'm planning to build my new pc
with a with the 3090 actually um
which i know is honestly people would
want to ask me i would say it's not
necessary getting a 30 90 is actually
dumb
you should get a 30 80. um obviously
don't know about amd at this point but
um i'm doing it because i do video edit
and i feel like that will be handy
i should change my settings first in it
okay
let's just go why don't we just go to a
high
just a high seems
okay pc loved that is happy about it
great [ __ ] news across the board
gonna be great gonna be great
i do have a good pc i really do can't
run crisis apparently
that's the news and this took ages first
as well
i would also guess that this is not
terribly well optimized but
uh people asking if i'm romanceable in
cyberpunk
i don't know why i didn't expect to get
asked that as much as i've been asked
um but i like i said i'm not allowed to
tell you anything about my quest
at all i'm not allowed to tell you
anything
i do edit in premiere pro yes
oh the loading bar is moving
uh how do i do that is that gonna be a
scroll wheel
not gonna be a it could be attached
honestly who knows
i don't know how much damage i do you
know what i'm saying
i feel like every time that i play an
old fps i'm like but what's the
situation
are they gonna die immediately or
my silencer is not on okay do i even
need to do this stealthy ana in a super
suit
i don't know that this is necessary
it is a stealth game i should i should
um what was it x to go to the
invisible key
i do like it well that seems like a nice
headshot so let's just do that
and then just do that you know was i
cloaked i'm unclear
good actually i'm just gonna keep
running
how's everybody feeling about how this
looks because that's really why i wanted
to play this
is like this is fun this is stupid and
fun
no one managed to be able to run that
bus
uh yeah i really just wanted to play
this after the trailers got such a
negative reception so i was like
i feel like it looks fine
okay why are we doing this
but why do when i could just scroll
wheel
if you want me to use my pistol i guess
i'll do it
oh oh oh oh man up here
now who the [ __ ] said that
there you are come on let's get the
aztec aztec
thank you thank you for instance
a dragon um yes
this printing is great yeah game does
have retracing i just don't have
uh race racing myself so
uh i got my pc right before
them cards came out so
okay cool let's just power through this
forest like a [ __ ] superhero
it's so ridiculous energy critical
it is true this lighting looks nice
though if you look at this
that's quite pretty the rock's not so
great but this looks very nice
you know what i'm saying
i did not remember this game being the
cinematic
they're really going for it i respect it
i really do
what the hell happened here
i am australian in cyberpunk i have said
for a long time bill that i am playing
nomad
which i would have done anyway um
but also i am only available in nomad so
there you have it
but yeah my voice in cyberpunk is just
my voice um
it's not my character at all though like
isn't it is not like me as a person at
all
something spooky's happening why you get
spookers on me i don't like this man
something's gonna jump out and i'm
nervous it's not even october yet this
is rude
i think i might do a halloween stream
situation though
[ __ ] okay well it wasn't scary
but i was mindly unsettled um
we'll take it what the hell is going on
out there i don't know
but i don't think we're alone out here
sir we got four dead koreans but there's
no way aztec killed
something else why does everyone keep
saying aztec for their bodies
what about aztecs sir is this gonna
leave him hanging here
negative i'm gonna vaporize we can't
allow the koreans to get their hands on
that suit
stand back
damn it
i guess this one has to teach you all
the lore of the suits huh
take care of his equipment and cover our
tracks
got it boss all right
yeah that's
got it i do like
ah switch fire mode on the weapon there
we go okay
good to know i ain't got that much time
though this is you're pretty far away
well that was very loud why i thought
that i was moving to something that was
going to be
silenced i feel like that was the setup
there that was
obnoxiously loud
not a good time man not a good time
not what i had planned at all blew my
uncover pretty bad
okay let me just figure this out what is
it so we do this two
oh it's just that i was shooting two
bullets that's cool
what's he doing that
i do like that actually quite a bit
yeah not being burst is nice
will i be streaming cold war uh probably
not i would if a friend asked but
i just lost don't tend to play call of
duty
location that's all right
it's very um
i want to say like dull but it's
actually not that bad
no i'm okay with it
it you definitely we're definitely
having some running problems but that's
probably
on my pc
is it going to give me a cool no i see a
large transmitting array
that must be the jamming station
the original far cry yep
great
cool okay why the music do this
okay where are you at though
right there me i like that
it's nice i like it oh i can always see
on my radar
well i'm invisible so what are they
gonna [ __ ] do about that then
it's nice it is nice oh you should be
dead
you should also be dead he is good
uh was the reinforcements that one guy
well okay
i'm trying to look at the lighting of
the video game can everyone please
calm down
oh that's the reinforcements well we're
gonna we're gonna casually walk away
from that i just wanted to look at these
bottles of plastic
you know what i'm saying if i could just
do that back here
it would be tight okay let's turn that
off
chill out
are you at sound of a [ __ ]
everybody dead now well what about you
though
didn't think that would work i'm gonna
go back and look at these bottles if
everyone could please calm down
no it's still happening that's what it
is it's it's the it's the
bug for a [ __ ] off i just want to look
at this
this lighting
i mean they're literally just
transparent that's not great
but
they look like they have cloaking um
not that that really matters okay so why
do you want me to go let me speed run
that shall i
he's dead but standing
okay cool very nice
the rtx for this game is in engine
that's interesting
uh ray tracing is generally turned on
for everything but i mean i don't have
ray tracing
so um
yeah okay where do you want me to go
where are we dropping what's the yellow
marker back here
is that this
excuse me i would like to order a hot
dog
please uh how to use
not sure what is the button to use
um i've tried all the usual suspects
shift try it no
no don't know i've tried pretty much
everything
that you would generally press to use
something in a video game
um f
didn't work are you did something break
in f
is that where thrust give me f's
uh enter no
um no
what if we just touch everything damn
binoculars
it did it great
i don't know what it was i literally
just pressed everything and it worked
brilliant
strange
what's up that way too
uh hello lads don't mind me i'm very
slow when i just walk at a regular pace
that's pretty rad can i shoot that down
no okay
i'm gonna change my fire mode
it did kill them neat
and then we zoom through like we're
[ __ ] sonic
i probably did accidentally remap it you
are probably right
um accidentally somehow i don't know
certainly wasn't anything it normally is
in video games
but it is also an old game things have
changed and i'm saying see this looks
nice
i feel good about this also i'm pretty
sure this game runs ultra wide
at least the menus did um
which we frankly love to see hey hey
my suit's fine bro chill out
what happens if i now do this
i'm not playing it like it's crisis is
really a large part
okay
we're fine we're fine i don't know why
everyone's so panicked i have so much
[ __ ] help what's the problem even you
know what i'm saying
i uh i've i've forgotten the strat
ultimately because it feels weird to
move so fast but be told to not be
aggressive
i guess that's it wants to be a cover
shooter
i straight up played that uh the
entirety of crisis three with i maxed
my cloak because i believe it had a
level system if i remember correctly
and the bow at the same time it ruled
so i was literally just predator the
whole [ __ ]
is he dead no i can't see you but i'm
guessing
there you are now i shouldn't have
cloaked that i should have almost
if we go armor when they're shooting me
it's the idea oh i'm running out of ammo
okay
time to steal somebody's weapons
where is it there it is
okay uh it's g
that's so weird
good day sir i said good day i still do
want to look at this water though but
then i'm worried that these guys are
going to shoot me and now apparently i
have no ammo
but like what does the water look like
you know is it like
paper mario good or what like what's the
situation
that's what i'm saying oh g for grab it
could be what's grenade don't know
you know what i'm going to punch in who
cares if i die am i right it's just
[ __ ]
punching
success and then that's going to be yeji
there's another [ __ ] up here
that i can just go punch
well he said if they spot me they'll
call in reinforcements were you talking
about these dudes because they've
certainly spotted me
i feel like this looks way better than
those trailers uh made it off
i have no [ __ ] ammo bro
i dropped my pistol in it oh hello
can i steal a weapon from you sir
oh that oh stuck okay
oh i can just drive all right bro these
[ __ ] [ __ ]
again i feel like what i wanted to see
is it is how it looked
um and i i totally think this looks
better than i thought
like that's that is my genuineness this
looks good
solid remaster that was excellent
watch out for the chickens you know
you just gotta you just gotta keep going
oh man indicates that the kpa have a
command post on the eastern peninsula
i need you to infiltrate and check for
intel on enemy placements
i'm uploading the coordinates now like
this looks nice
y'all trying to get run over
surely that worked i feel like
this is a nightmare to drive oh my gosh
the tree stuff it's good it's good we
like it
so awful
i've damaged this car significantly too
man you're closing in on that command
post
i suggest you switch to cloak and sneak
in undetected
i have no ammo though fram it's it's not
looking good out here
i should probably go back in theory but
uh
it's you know it's fine
just try to [ __ ] punch some [ __ ]
is what i'm gonna do until i get
some ammo
cloak engaged
engage skull with shotgun yes
yes okay oh it came back oh [ __ ] what
so where did you come from
it's a nice shotgun ammo is also low
we just got to steal people's [ __ ]
uh yeah we want that i'm gonna take that
you're gonna take it you're gonna take
it
okay great
watch out for that grenade
didn't mean to press e there that's my
bad
the whole part of this game feels like
yesterday i mean this feels old
for sure because it is but i'm into it
look i guess engaged
i wish there was a stealth kill because
again i know
oh what are you sitting on there bud
what's uh
what's going on here you ain't seen [ __ ]
how about that how about i do that
oh i blew myself up
but i i wear a super suit that doesn't
make any sense
am i going to sneak in undetected now
okay
engaged
y'all already dead is that what's
happened to you
i got no ammo nope that one out
i saw him immediately excellent hey
control
that's strange
just hang out here i guess you know
just hang out chill out
this is going to be a problem we're
going to have a problem with this
because i do not have
the arsenal to make it work
oh it's the same guys they just brought
her up
oh [ __ ] that's too many of you son of a
[ __ ]
what am i supposed to do i ain't got a
[ __ ] ammo
i'm gonna wait for my suit to come back
is what i'm gonna do sprint away
like the mad lad i am
wait for suit
this is not a good time this is not a
good time i [ __ ] up here
again the game looks pretty good uh
comes out tomorrow
i will take whatever you have please
dear god
yes thank you okay
quite good
get your get your oh
uh suit
no we don't need two of the same [ __ ]
ones a shotgun back
um suit into sprint shotgun
is uh is good stuff
real [ __ ] ammo situation's still
going on though so i'm going to get rid
of
hang on i'm going to get rid of the
shotgun no i don't have it
no no no no no no wait we're gonna we're
gonna do this we're gonna do this
okay the shotgun should still be in
theory
there right
all right this [ __ ] he tried to turn
around like he's still on the gun
that's so cute i love that for you
pretty flowers i again feel like it
looks pretty good looks way better than
those trailers made it look
uh not running super smoothly
oh and i don't know if that's my fault
or not
feel like it's not though
my situation got away [ __ ] out of
hands
what did this dude have
thanks lab um
it's possible that like twitch did have
a crisis one or definitely didn't have
crisis remastered as an option when i
was selecting the game it's possible
that it had crysis one but
because i set it up through restream it
may just be that the restream option
wasn't showing
i don't have anything silenced now
anyway though so i don't know how much
use this is going to be govern me
you've been covered sir you've been
covered does anyone have any [ __ ]
ammo that i can take
please sports thank you holy [ __ ]
yeah we'll take that too
this music is a choice
all right i think everybody's dead good
news
yeah i'm assuming that this performance
uh issues
i'm inside my pc but i don't understand
see if you can access their tactical
network
you change the music what do you mean
the game kind of does look like far cry
3 yeah i think it's older though like
what
did actual crisis come out crisis
release date
2007 far cry 3
wasn't far cry 3 one of the 2012 games
the great year of 2012.
um
got it i'm in downloading now i don't
remember him sounding like this in three
either
got the intel proceeding to rendezvous
good work no man
i was doing rambo style yeah but that's
only because i don't have any ammo which
i don't
i think it's because i didn't kill
enough people
looks like
pretty sure
is crisis three a different protagonist
i the law got confusing on me in theory
you shouldn't live at the end of crisis
too because
of the suit if i remember correctly
i don't know
uh where do you want me to go
is it back to the green
because i don't know if it is what's my
objective fam
got it wonderful okay
break through the kpa checkpoint
understood
you have no [ __ ] ammo though so
that's
there we go energy critical
fine we'll just walk very slowly i did
want to look at the beach let's go do
that how's the water look
that's what i'm here for i just wanted
to see how video game look
i mean
you know besides
i would swim in this
it's night it's fine
it's fine
yeah no uh this looks better than
everyone feared is what is my hot take
i think they're like just up here if i
look at this they are
what am i gonna no you ain't seen [ __ ]
what are you talking about you [ __ ]
punk
as if that wasn't a headshot are you
[ __ ] me
okay pistol's a bad idea would have
thought those men were dead
but they had oh oh oh where'd you come
from
they didn't die so
unexpected unexpected turn of events
expected them to die
from pistol they did not
uh video games have changed ladies and
gentlemen
people used to take a lot longer to kill
it's known
it is known
[ __ ] you up on a beach i'd love to bro i
thought you'd never ask
this shotgun is incredible
obviously that range is not quite gonna
work for me
still great though still a fan
it's beautiful it's really it's really
something
wow hair in my own eye okay sure
we'll take you it was nothing don't
worry about it
um i'm still a little bit concerned
about my ammo situation
so if everyone could just chill the [ __ ]
out that would be tight
what
it's not good it's not good
and i'm getting very hot because my pc
is definitely running hot energy
critical
my energy's fine don't worry about it
can i kill someone by throwing a chicken
at them i don't think so did someone say
he's giving you rage 2 vibes i mean
speed wise maybe but one of the things
in
rage 2. um is that you can
uh people die pretty fast they fall
pretty quick
uh and i think that's just a modern
video games thing you know what i'm
saying
i play a lot of doom one like quite
frequently
is there a way for me to just
circumnavigate everyone and just get up
here
i think there is road back this way
no it's not um
well yeah everyone takes a [ __ ]
million shots zephyr
you're real basic dudes i don't even
know where i was being shot at from then
but we're not in a good spot here i got
too distracted by looking at pretty
things
that's why women women shouldn't play
video games you know what i'm saying
okay we're gonna recharge
we'll get cloak and i still don't know
exactly how to quit my silencer
so engaged
where are you at though need support
you need support dear i'm here to
support you fam
need help yeah i'd love to help
we need to back up yeah i'm helping i'm
here i've come
i've come to serve giving me back up
[ __ ] really
[ __ ] running shotgun again you know
what i'm saying it works
so all right
i thought i was invisible clearly not
invisible enough
for some reason let me have it give me
everybody just give me [ __ ] ammo
let me just walk around and spam it
maybe that'll work
the pistol did just destroy the entire
wall this was not well put together
and i also don't feel like i was really
shooting at it but uh it's fine
okay hang on what's up with this i
should have done that
very nice nice work oh there's so many
of them too
i can take grenades now g to select
grenade
oh well but then what's gonna happen to
g now
now i'm scared g's been pick up
beautiful checks out can confirm is
grenade
now it's f
that's strange
the game just i don't i don't know what
i've done here i feel like i [ __ ]
something up the game just
changed to f upon g being occupied by a
grenade
all right i guess uh what's up with
future fashion i don't want to throw
this i want to read this are you kidding
me
no no the next gen super suit
we talk with the designer of the new
super suit of the future fashion capital
pyongyang
is the fashion capital of the woe
of the world now in north korea there
you go you guys there you go
all right well i guess f has picked
stuff up now so at least i feel more
comfortable
they they took the they took the g's and
they turned them in
f's
and that is what future fashion looks
like it's true oh my god it's true
god of war came out five years after ps4
came out
i mean i certainly know it was my game
of the year aggressively
uh that was a fun one because i read
dead
two came out the same year yeah it did
and the red dead fans were on me hard
about it because god all came out so
early and i was like i'm telling y'all
there's another game in the air i'm
telling you there's no [ __ ] way it's
not and they were like yeah
yeah it's like red red redemption which
i also think is fantastic but god of war
brilliant probably should have stealth
this one
what is your suggestion here i just have
to get through the checkpoint well
um i have grenades now
that's cute that you think that you
could do that too but
what if i do that you know
love that we have f we didn't [ __ ]
kill anyone
oh no i did quite dead
where the rest of these markers you're
saying are right here
right here up the hill my hands
all right here we go
you just [ __ ] kill your bro bye
i think there's one more right here
the camera is quite good i'll give them
that
these koreans in their future fashion
are onto something
quite good camo could i do a valley girl
voice the whole stream i mean i could
it's not difficult for me to do but it
makes me feel bad about myself
since it's too loud just chill out of it
yeah i mean i could do it as like a
i am planning to do another charity
screen this month that was a nice one oh
oh it wasn't a nice one
brilliant yeah well [ __ ] each shotgun
that was too bad aiming
hmm yes it's f now
i love it i love it so much how weird
um what was i saying i always forget i'm
sorry
bro where have you gone down
you have several men down actually i've
made him speak to you about that did you
also
like to go down
i don't think this is where i'm even
supposed to be but dude flexible for me
i don't know
uh what was i saying oh more charity
streams yeah i thought i'd do a couple
more fire early streams
maybe friday something maybe a cute
little friday situation that might
happen
where i don't know where that is but i
will take it
um and i am not against
yeah chuck a tantrum see that looked
pretty good
uh i'm not against having you know timed
chunks for valley girl but i also know a
lot of people find it very grating
tantrum
you haven't showered in 12 days should
you shower um
honestly look i'm going to say yes on
like a social level like you should
probably shower
but honestly like a a health level
do you need to shower that frequently i
would think
that if you used a bidet you'd actually
be a little bit more okay because i
believe it is feces that specifically
cause major issues for your skin um i
would definitely recommend showering
daily for the recording shower after
exercise every day otherwise i feel
[ __ ] disgusting
but uh like honestly from a science
level
you have anyone who knows science [ __ ]
i don't know if you have to shower if
you're just chilling at home
during covered i don't know if you'll
make yourself sick you know what i'm
saying
i don't know making a dull two weeks is
a pretty good call
what if you just waited two weeks
science says yes science says daily
showers baby skin i thought so
let's look it up how often do i need
to shower for health
well there is no ideal frequency experts
suggest sharing several times per week
is plenty for most people
unless you are grimy sweaty i have other
reasons short showers
focus on armpits or groin may suffice so
i guess you're actually generally okay
um
not showering with that much frequency
jesus
uh as long as you're not
getting mad sweaty because then it will
damage your
skin
i you know when a new game is released
that i really dammit
strengths jump come on but that i've
really wanted to get through
um i you know i've sat in front of a tv
and got pretty disgusting and sweaty
for a couple of days i have done that a
number of times in my life
uh 12 days is a whole other thing though
i would start to hate myself
i don't even know how you've managed
that
okay
wow that's quite a biome change about
time you showed up
is it cocaine you believe this
snow cane looks like someone had a
little trouble [ __ ] their boat
you seem to have hit a dead end i've
lost your channel
two of those like action hero lines in a
row
come on i've got something topographic
map
there's an area highlighted a good
valley here must be where the excavation
site is located how can you be sure
yeah i'm not but it's all we've got to
go on we need to get moving i'm not
going anywhere until you give me
some us his faces are right and i say
that as someone who says that about
their own face
when do the north koreans have
themselves that dude
that's it i feel like i jumped into a
bloody comic book
what's going on i've told you everything
you need to know
that's bollocks and you know it aztec is
dead and we
ain't got that at least he says aztec
and not aztec boss
he was mutilated ripped in two i mean
what are we dealing with here
because it ain't just korean jester's
right if this
rosenthal
something's here
see i certainly remember that we have to
go we have to go now
i'm like really into this in a way that
i didn't remember and it like
yeah the the effort in the law is a lot
uh better than i remember or expected
especially for the game that everyone
says this is the one that you just break
your pc with right like that's what
crysis was known for
but now they got a [ __ ] story going
on here again
i was a fan of crisis 3. i really
enjoyed that game
um stay on track i didn't finish one i
did finish two
let's go let's go maybe i will play this
my issue right now is that i don't feel
like i've got the gameplay loop down
because i'm playing it like it's a
modern shooter when it certainly is not
um it's a superhero game that happens to
feature guns
is what it actually is which means i'm
playing it incorrectly at present
but yeah like crysis 3
it has all the [ __ ] crazy
supernatural boss fight [ __ ] going on
i think i might finish this how long is
it let's take a look
how long how long is crisis one
how long to beat 11 hours mate
mate we can do that we can finish this
game i'm going to do it
yeah plays like doom 2016 it doesn't
play like doom 2016
um no no i don't agree with that
i don't need to move anywhere near as
much
uh
just not even at all i don't even know
where to give you points on that
oh it doesn't it doesn't feel like um
i've played a lot of [ __ ] doom in my
time one of my favorite video game
franchises ever
but look at this got these cut scenes
you know
i should [ __ ] go for it whoa i'm not
gonna play the whole thing tonight no
i was only going to stream for an hour
just to really just to show you guys the
graphics that was the whole point of
this stream is
generally any time i get a game early um
i will do streams that are
intended to just answer questions people
have had about the thing before they buy
it so
thank you john hands your unhelpful
comment on parasite
whenever someone apologizes to me for
something that they've said on the
internet
um i always want to say i promise i
don't remember
at all i don't know what you said and i
certainly wasn't offended by it uh
that's never an issue um so no need to
apologize
it's all good i do also have a habit of
i feel like it's clear in videos or
streams or whatever that i
am very chill um but of a text
i always just come across as angrier
than i am it's the way that i type
is always more aggressive than i ever
intend to be it is an ongoing issue that
i have in my life
i need to put more smiley faces on [ __ ]
so sometimes that people think i'm
reading something i'll be
like someone will be like whoa why did
you sorry if i offended you and i'd be
like how did you even get that you
thought that you offended i
my reply was so basic i don't understand
just add a smiley face on the end alana
it's not that difficult
but yes bad at text communication it's a
thing
i think being too one or two direct
makes people think you are upset when
really i'm just trying to be efficient
this is one of the ways in which i am
socially inept welcome
eyes yeah i think i just need a smiley
face
i am gonna be honest i do think some of
it is like is a little bit harder when
you're a woman like that
i don't think it's entirely texas it's
totally on me but i think sometimes i'm
like i swear to god if a man wrote that
you would have been fine
but because i wrote it like god there
was one that was so weird recently
uh this dude asked me about my i have
all these collectibles on the top of my
kitchen cabinets and some guy was like
have you ever had them fall over in an
earthquake
and my response was something like no
the lip is very high and the breakable
stuff is far back so i'm not concerned
about it falling over in an earthquake
and someone responded and was like i
don't understand why you're so rude in
response to everything and i was like
what how what
just put smiley faces on the end of your
comments
alana or you come across as mad all the
time
so [ __ ] weird nothing but bodies
it is my fault though i need to not
blame other people for it i am the one
who's bad at it it's feedback i've
gotten my whole life
bad at text communication oh
no i was so excited to throw that at
someone
all right listen up in the village about
a click ahead
could be one of rosenthal's crew no man
i need you to infiltrate the village and
gather any intel you can
yeah i'll stay here and monitor incoming
comms by gather intel
do you mean go in shoot
and then look at a screen
village that's so far away
i think being straight to the point is
efficient again
i really do think that but it is
frequent
frequent that uh people tell me that
like they'll be like oh sorry if i upset
you and i'm like oh what
no you didn't you didn't know something
i just replied a [ __ ]
so i don't know i don't know i feel like
i'm doing something wrong
yeah so i i feel like i remember in
crisis three you could upgrade your [ __ ]
intel suggests snipers up ahead i'm
moving out to secure location i'll keep
you briefed
i could drive but i could also
i was wondering what was gonna happen
man
what are you doing bud what were you
what we all just
they were just like oh hey hey
everyone now he's thinking that about me
he's like what is this [ __ ] doing
just going for a jog mate you're gonna
go for a run or something
um i guess we're gonna do it we're gonna
do it
we're gonna we're gonna it's all driving
is awful but
we're gonna oh it's choppy i'm gonna
just turn settings down
real quick
i'm totally gonna finish this game
that's what we wanted to do we're just
gonna go with a medium
so at least we can see the difference
and see if the chops still exist
in a medium that's what i'm trying to
figure out
i do want to use these settings what are
we having trouble getting me to medium
now
mate that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense
uh andrew no it is not the streaming
that causes the chops
i think this game is poorly optimized is
my guess
my pc is pretty beefy but crisis is
beefia
which i think they've inflated what
buddy tab out
tab back mate
my buddy my guy why is this happen
it doesn't make sense
no okay well i don't know why this
happened
but i guess it did oh
look at you you got medium to work
bam i am [ __ ] proud of you look at
you go you little video game okay i feel
like this is already smoother
what's up
you guys aren't gonna believe this but
it sounds like general reach on kyong is
in charge of the whole operation
the guy behind that massacre a few years
back
i don't know it looks great okay
okay okay i wanna use the minigun
and i'm not sure how to do it
uh no unclear scratch that plan okay
um what am i gonna do i'm gonna throw a
grenade that's probably what i'm gonna
do
do a nice grenade throw yeah
and then another one and then just like
another one
[ __ ] hole three of them
shut your damn helmet off your head son
punch
all right hey lad what did you think you
were doing
not good ai we'll give him that to shoot
in the car
i could have but i am no longer there
it's fine we've moved on
yeah boss oh my ammo's full we've come
so far
this is crazy
i feel so secure
hang on he's the other way no no he is
this way
he's just chilling
he's just chilling
could have taken that vehicle but i
didn't want to
this game is way more open than it has
any right to be
i do keep forgetting how fast that runs
out though so that's the thing
funhouse has to play this i don't know
that we would do a fun house gameplay
for this i guess it is broken it is a
good point i could float that with the
team
i'm working on producing some halloween
content for us right now
they have not fixed the dumb ai no it's
still bad
thank you for your work scooterman
gaming
i appreciate you
uh calvin that would have been me
probably
yeah i asked if i joined a video game
channel so yeah like
i to get experience doing video stuff
worked for a bunch of established
channels or established brands and was
like hey
let me make video game new stuff you i
will write it and edit it and host it
um because i wanted to have professional
experience
so i have worked for a lot of weird
youtube channels or really small brands
that's really how i got my start was
that exact hustle was
finding people i could work for
and uh doing it for free
or like you know
pitching them something um so that i
could work with people and get feedback
and oh look what hey you would well
there's that house gone
sup cups
i have arrived
um yeah and working for free is
definitely a contentious topic but it is
always my
all right all right mate all right oh
doing way too much hip shooting with
that gun i should just change the
shotgun
that is what we want um
my suggestion to people who want to get
into what i do they're always like what
where do i start
invent jobs that's how i got where i am
today because i created jobs where there
weren't any so i could get experience
and you can absolutely still do that
reach out to people and offer to edit
reach out to people and offer a host
even if it's a facebook page or a small
community or like a youtube channel
that's really tiny that you like just
pitch them something that
that helps them and that's that's
literally how i did it invented jobs
where they didn't exist
otherwise i would not be where i am
today you must be close
okay
definitely still here hey guys what's up
all right
everybody was being very rude there so
i'm just gonna
oh
that was not good
okay
i'm having trouble just figuring out
where the [ __ ] they're coming from
where did you come from
oh [ __ ] she's kind of hot easy darling
oh to you hello i'm okay it's not my
blood
hey what's up oh [ __ ]
girl you singing something tomorrow to
pieces yeah we're sorry we thought no
one was coming for us
what took you some no baby i'm here well
we had a little trouble
finding your boat oh baby our boat our
boat's gone
i contacted langley a week ago when no
one came we made a break for the harbor
but something
something doesn't want us here something
out there they literally have
boob physics the boobs jiggle when she
talks
which is so funny because that doesn't
happen excavation
speed bumps it's easy speed bumps are at
night
when you have to don't know what they
found terrifying every time you have to
wait
speaking breathing not going back not so
much i
barely made it out alive that's too much
it's too much jiggly listen to me we've
been monitoring rosenthal's work i'm not
a fan of her neck
i still think she cute though in the
jungle only it's
it's not a statue her face is scary
everyone's scary roosevelt thinks it's
evidence of a dead civilization
we don't like it we're not so sure we
don't we don't like
ah an earthquake we woke it up you may
not have much time get out of hand
rosenthal's team out of here and secure
this island
whatever this thing is you can't let the
koreans have it
can't let the koreans have whatever this
thing is that's what i'm saying
you'd better get out of there fast you
take care of those tanks no man i think
it's his eyes
i don't know he's got a beaky mouth or
something's [ __ ] off with their faces
but hey
it's whatever it's not a new game we've
got a kpa armor
okay
oh well this is a good looking room we
like all of this
so i know well i don't think i want
you know hello i want the brand grenades
but i will take this
well i shouldn't be using it in here
sick oh that's a tank
okay
just let me get my health back
is it her even playing are you [ __ ]
stupid
what is wrong with you
what is wrong with you god
the incident [ __ ] idiot
okay good day
now tank time maybe mayhaps with this
no i'm just trying to [ __ ] up a tank man
i love it
it's there okay oh my god it's so
intimidating i don't know why
usually i'm not afraid of a tank in a
video game
uh one wanna do this
tank stop leaving [ __ ] come hang out
dude
oh this is it
there are two they're off too tanks yes
brilliant i feel like i should kill
little guys first ah
got stuck in a tree
kill little guys and then take out tanks
is going to be the strat
hank really does seem to want my dick
there are too many of you and it's very
chaotic but the game is running
beautiful
so we thought about that
i just need to get some cover
hey buddy
there we go
i made a [ __ ] mess of that so let's
do it now i know there's two tanks
they're gonna be fine that was a [ __ ]
disaster i was very uncoordinated it was
not a good time
it was not a good time
but at least i have ammo what clearly
that's not what i wanted
sometimes you just gotta sing paramore
to soothe yourself um
you know what i'm saying should have
merely the tank
could have
i do not know the sound here though no i
don't want the flashbang we've been over
this we definitely
will hold up i can change grenade type
ah i can have both in my inventory i did
not realize
this where are you thinking about what
what was what was the plan with that
come back where did you go excuse me sir
why aren't you helping either
are they both on the roof
this is so noisy
no i could do that i could also
this game is so [ __ ] bizarre what are
you doing
ai it's too noisy it's just too noisy i
was trying to turn my volume down
it's too much [ __ ] noise it is
overwhelming
uh how is this a remaster it looks
exactly like the original version
you'd have to see them side by side
there's this uh we spoke about this on
play watch listen this week i think
maybe i think i asked them literally
about crisis
um
uh your memory remembers video games
differently to how they actually looked
so you remember them looking better than
than than is reality um
i you'd have to see them side by side
actually now
i shot you in the knees so many times
though
something about this is like making me
mad anxious and how [ __ ] noisy it is
three tanks oh hey bud
hey see you there babe
what was that it's just
it's just a lot it's just a lot first
it does sound nice but i like my shotgun
a lot
that's what i wanted tank two
is it just two though
come on
difficult to play while talking so
if it gets overwhelming i'm just gonna
have to shut up a bit
so i can just play the video game which
is fine
you have several men now you keep
reporting it like it's new news
it is the news is not new no
it's several i don't even what's this
look at him
ah hey that let me look let me honor
your dead friend you son of a [ __ ]
he was going like
man
yeah he was giving me a thumbs up on his
way out it was a real [ __ ] uh
terminator situation
you must be close yeah dude i'm super
close you didn't know that i was on this
roof for some reason
well okay i shot that first guy point
blank but
all right okay let's keep remembering to
use our superpowers
where y'all at why do you keep moving
what is this ai
guy oh [ __ ]
where's thumbs up guys this him a lot
stop falling for it stop falling for
laughing at them that's how you end up
dead
am i okay bud
where are you gonna be like here
somewhere i think probably there you are
all right i love that this shotgun
literally lifts them off their feet
it's incredible okay now we're allowed
to make fun of people and i bet you
nobody's gonna have an interesting pose
in sight
boring deaths well now that one's pretty
good
i like that one does this make me a
serial killer
this is some victor's ass [ __ ]
ah yeah i'm just gonna just gonna spam
that
because we come so far you know it's
just so nice
f works for a while it was g i still
there's too many [ __ ] out here that's
what i'm saying
where you at though
i tried to do that like doom it did not
work
are they still in the building is that
what that was happening
they might be what if we just do this
do you know i'm here
oh there he is there's still someone
alive don't do it yet
you can come back to him he will stay
there he's going to be up
you're going to die will i okay there
you are
there you are
you want to see that
did anyone else see that what just
happened there
is that uh
has it been happening the whole time
because i feel like i am losing
orientation of people but there also are
just a lot of them
is that you from who from there is that
what you've done
there are two of you
hi [ __ ]
i keep thinking this shotgun has more of
a spread than it does
it is extremely narrow it is literally
right i think
at least i just want to look at this
dude
yeah virtually no spread on this shotgun
right
real direction oh that got hairy
okay is everyone dead now so i can
admire this dude
hey bud okay what are you doing here
it's definitely like a sort of this
situation but it's sort of he's doing
like a
it's beautiful thank you
it's [ __ ] up i should see a
psychologist about that
again victor's ass i will take all of
the shotgun
thank you rendezvous point okay let's go
let's go sup [ __ ]
mate mate what happened there
it's fine
all right i look like i'm roller skating
to the extraction point
i have no idea how that shot didn't hit
it doesn't make any sense i think that
the game is maybe broken
i think that what happens is when you're
sprinting and you shoot
i'm transmitting my coordinates it's
ahead of itself
if that makes sense all right mate
we did it this is pretty right
rainbow there you go you guys we figured
it out is the game bad
no could a bad game do that
no this is gay as hell
yeah beautiful work
we've we've solved the mystery of if the
crisis remaster looks worse than the
original
i'm gonna be honest i really don't think
it does so let's pull up
original crisis images
i mean this isn't max settings
no it totally looks better if i show you
guys this
save this oh my god crisis oh my god why
you
why are you like this it's uh
a series of
things that this game does um what's it
going to be what was that file
f of
blue whoop do that
this is what the game originally
looked like yeah
at um i mean the screenshot said max
settings
you should [ __ ] get smaller there's
there's another way to do this on ibs
that i'm just not familiar with yet what
is it like hold and drag or something i
don't remember
i have too many [ __ ] tabs open anyway
uh
uh is this original video game or is
this remastered though because that i
don't buy it
that does look the same i don't buy that
give me original crisis screenshots
oh you can change the shotgun spread if
you change firing mode thank you for
that i would definitely prefer to
hold alt and drag is that it alt drag
no
oh well that's crop i don't that's cool
though
um
but i don't know that that's even the
right image that i was trying to look at
that is way too high-res to be og crisis
crisis original well that looks awful
it's hard to find an original one
because all the news right now is
obviously about
the remaster but this is a comparison
photo let's pull that one up
here we go
there that one
this image just not loaded what's your
problem with this one
bro either way that doesn't
translate well to stream as it turns out
it totally looks better
well i know i can fit to screen but hang
on why is this not working
what have you done image let's get rid
of it and then just add it back in
add an image okay go browse go
crisis remastered okay beautiful so if i
do this fit to screen
i mean it'll stretch but you're right
you're super right
i use that all the time for my webcam
this is like someone else's comparison
how
how close do we feel like my gameplay
looks to that
if i then do an alt alt
drag nope [ __ ]
bastard there we go okay okay this is
the best we could do
we're making it work let's find a tree
i mean it totally looks better
right
it's more colorful
it's obviously not the same area because
i don't know where that specific [ __ ]
tree is but
buddy buddy guy
not the finest player
here a tree
let's worry about it it's
the lighting obviously feels like
contrast saturation ohio
it's not overly saturated though but i
think video games had this period of
time where like especially around the
time the first gears came out where
everything was just gray
i don't know why but clearly it's more
colorful um
yeah shadows are better
i don't know that the textures look
terribly different but
i think it looks way fun about it trying
to tell me it looks the same
come on right image not at ultra
settings
left image also not at ultra settings
i'm only playing on medium right now so
i think it looks better that's the
synopsis also
terrible game to play on stream because
i was not paying enough attention to
what i was doing
um and again this doesn't play like a
normal fps is the big
the big thing that i have to remember
but i really
am into it i think i'm probably gonna
finish this how does the fps feel as in
like the first person shooting or the
frames per second
i don't know i don't know
fallout 3 is ugly as hell it's one of
those green gray games
yeah around that era where they were
green and gray all the time
the left is less realistic i mean
is it though i think that those are just
two
different environments frankly the right
one looks like the australian bush
the left one looks like an australian
rainforest i feel like i've seen both of
these things in existence
it's a good point scooterman gaming you
should just go check out digitalfoundry
that's a better idea
that is a better idea
but uh yeah all right i think i'm gonna
wrap the stream up there
i feel like i'm gonna finish this game
i'm into it i like it
good stuff and uh
yeah the ai is really bad the game's
glitchy
um but it's certainly unique
and yeah they put more effort into the
narrative than
than expected so i
am into it uh i will see you all
tomorrow morning if anyone's watching
the
night city wire live i'm gonna be
hosting that for twitch gaming at
twitch.tv
twitch gaming i believe it is um
show starts at 8 30. night city y starts
at nine
i will be on as soon as night city wire
ends which i think is going to be from
like maybe like 9 25 or something
so yeah unique equals i haven't played
no unique is that crisis plays like
you're a superhero like i said i loved
crysis 3 for that
um when will we see the new play watch
listen uploaded play watch listen goes
up every friday
sometimes on a saturday if we have to
but generally every friday so that will
be before or friday
that's the case uh otherwise
i will see you guys have a good one
thanks for watching
i have to really tab out of this game
aggressively okay now